-Obviously, you've worked in
Boston before --
"Mystic River," "Patriots Day.
What is it like
working in Boston
versus other filming locales
-Well, I love working in Boston.
This is probably my sixth or
seventh thing I've done there.
I don't really know why I keep
getting Boston gigs, but I do.
And, you know,
Boston is so interesting,
because everybody has
a really great sense of
this history of the city,
but it's not just --
It's, like, real old
historical stuff like,
"Oh, you know,
the colonials, you know,
died there" or something.
I don't even know.
-Yeah, yeah.
-I'm not big on history.
But then it's also, like,
more recent stuff, like,
"You know, my cousin
knows the guy that was shot.
You know, he was connected to --
You know, like, right in tha
alley right there."
You know, it's --
And, so, you always get this -
It also feels like a super
super small town, you know
Everybody knows everybody.
Everybody knows everything
about everybody that's going on.
I have a great fondness for it
-It is true that if you ar
nice to people in Boston,
everybody knows by
the next time you got back
because they all do
know each other.
-Yes. Yes.
-Like, I'll go back,
and they'll be like,
"Hey, my cousin Tommy worked the
door at your last show.
He said you're a class act
I really appreciate it."
You're like, "Oh."
-Right. Right. Right.
And everybody
has a friend that knows a guy.
-Yeah, they do.
They're very --
I want to ask about this,
because your first --
Not a lot of people have suc
iconic first roles or films.
"Animal House."
-Uh-huh.
-You were in "Animal House."
You were 18 years old.
-Yeah.
-Were other people
in that movie --
At that point,
were they all starting out
Were there people --
Was John Belushi famous?
-John Belushi was famous because
he was on "Saturday Night Live."
-Yeah.
-And -- Have you heard of it
-Oh, yeah.
-And he was -- You know,
he was on "Saturday Night Live
and also was at that
pinnacle of, like,
his greatness
on "Saturday night live."
And he was traveling
back and forth
from "SNL," in New York,
and we were shooting
all the way out in Oregon.
And he was the first real,
you know, celebrity
that I ever met --
and certainly movie star.
And so I was really, really,
like, taken with him,
and he was a very, very
generous and warm guy.
I'll never forget --
he did a party
that I got invited to.
And we were all staying
at this crappy hotel,
and he had a house,
a rented house.
I think it was by the water.
And he had everybody come over
And he had brunch and he had
flown lox from New York,
and that blew my mind that
first off,
he would have a party, be able
to afford it,
and that they would go to --
It was, like, Zabar's,
Barney Greengrass, or something.
Get this giant --
And I had ever ate lox
because it was too expensive
-Yeah.
-And there was just piles of it.
It was that combined with
the first time
that I had ever heard of
a mimosa.
-Oh, wow.
-Yeah.
So this was a really, really
major point in my life.
-Yeah.
-Along with meeting John.
-I mean, to be introduced to lox
and mimosas on the same day...
-Yes. By John Belushi.
-By John Belushi. You're right
-Yeah.
-That's a lot better.
I think mine was, like,
my Aunt Christy. Yeah.
You know her.
-Yeah. Yeah.
Cousin Christy.
-Hey, thanks so much
for being here.
It's always such a pleasure.
Kevin Bacon, everybody.